Hey, you busy?
Oh no, I'm
just browsing new sources.
Come in, come in, bitch,
what's up?
Well, you know I'm just getting
over breast cancer, right?
I know, I know.
God.
Your cancer is like, all
I think about.
Really?
Pretty much.
I bet you don't think about it
as much as I think about it.
Well, I think about
it more than you'd think.
Well, good, then
you'll probably be excited
about the reason for
my visit.
There's a 5K breast cancer
run in a few weeks
and I'm trying to
get people--
Stop immediately.
Sold.
Of course, I'm in.
What's the maximum pledge?
50, 100, what?
There's actually
not a maximum pledge.
Okay, okay, 25.
That's really generous
of you--
Oh, it's nothing.
But I was wanting to see if
you would be willing
to run it with me.
Run--
Like, how
do you mean?
You know, I mean, you're
a thing.
People would be excited
to pay money for you to run.
Yeah, I don't know that I'm
a thing, you know.
I mean, I do get recognized
a lot, but--
I mean, I don't know.
Are other people from the
office, like,
physically
running this thing?
Yes.
Like who?
Gabe.
Gay.
Grace.
Lonely!
Kurt.
Oh, God,
he was raised by people
that weren't his biological
parents.
Okay, okay.
That's awesome.
The office is represented,
all right?
The problem is
with me, I can't.
I can't run, because I bulk
up super fast.
Just like thunder thighs.
It's so embarrassing.
Just, God, I really trust you,
that's why I'm telling you.
Amy, the reason to run is to
help raise awareness.
Awareness for what?
C-Cancer?
Like, I think
people have gotten the memo.
Yeah, I got the memo,
that's why
I had a double mastectomy.
When is it again?
Next Saturday.
Oh, balls!
You said Saturday, right?
Oh, I can't, that is so--
God, timing.
I have a
Kentucky Derby party that day,
and trust me, I would love
to cancel
but I
already bought a hat.
And those are only hats that
you would wear at,
like, you know--
They're not,
like, all-purpose hats, so.
Mmm.
( phone ringing )
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Hi, this is Amy.
Oh, hi Jeff Probst.
Yeah, definitely,
Saturday?
Yes, I'll be there,
of course I'll be there.
Can I wear a hat?
Jeff?
Okay, you already know
who that was.
Jeff Probst.
So this is
totally gonna cheer you up.
Okay, so Saturday, P. Diddy
is having, like,
a dance-a-thon to
raise money for chinchillas.
So they can be used in
coats again.
Oh, God.
But look, I'm so sorry.
Is there anything else I can
do for you?
Like, anything else?
I'm sorry that
my calendar is so booked.
Actually, yeah.
A bunch of friends were gonna
shave their heads
for when I
go through chemo.
So...
Okay.
That's great.
I can't
do that, obviously,
'cause a lot of people's jobs
are dependent on me
just kind of
keeping this look, you know?
But I'll tell you what
I will do.
I will continue to
get rid of all of my pubes.
Mmm.
( phone ringing )
This is Amy.
Hi, Nick Cannon.
I actually know Nick, tell
him I said hi.
Oh Nick,
Tig says hi.
Yeah, oh my God,
of course,
of course
I'm doing her 5K, yeah.